[Musique]
pour analyser cette décision de l'oblage
m'entretien avec Johan labroque et les
professeurs honoraires au département de
marketing du HEC bonsoir madame la break
bonsoir alors comment vous analysez
cette décision là de l'aublat est-ce que
c'est un vrai désir de diminuer le
fardeau de l'inflation comme le dit
l'entreprise ou c'est un coup de
marketing
la preuve qu'on en parle on en a parlé
aujourd'hui toute la journée maintenant
l'idée c'est vraiment de jouer sur la
perception prix puis aussi de montrer
qu'on est vraiment un bon citoyen là
pour se pencher sur les augmentations de
prix en période de très inflationniste
de façon assez marquée bon madame la
vraie quand on parle d'un gel de prix
c'est pas des prix qui descendent c'est
simplement des prix qui cesse
d'augmenter
1500 produits que le fait concrètement
ça peut avoir sur la facture d'épicerie
des consommateurs
mais ça va dépendre des consommateurs ce
n'est pas des paniers d'épicerie des
consommateurs donc vous l'avez montré ce
ne sont pas toutes les catégories de
produits ce sont pas tous les produits
qui sont touchés en magasin donc si on
regarde dans un magasin escompte de type
maxi autour de 10000 références alors
c'est ce ne sont pas tous les produits
et ce sont des prix qui sont fixes mais
faut penser que la négociation de prix
entre les distributeurs et les
fournisseurs se fait ce pour une durée
fixe une durée de quelques mois parfois
même plusieurs mois donc
de cette entendu avec les fournisseurs
pour stabiliser les prix surtout faut
remarquer que on arrive à la période la
plus créative juin des ventes
alimentaires ça va couvrir la période
des fêtes donc c'est une période qui est
très importante pour les joueurs de la
distribution on peut comprendre que on
voulait être proactif pour justement
fidéliser une clientèle avec une telle
ta mais un impact qui pourrait somme
toute être limité sur la facture
d'épicerie madame la vraie question
aurait fallu aller plus loin par exemple
je l'ai les prix de plus de produits ou
en faire plus de manière générale pour
limiter les augmentations
c'est difficile d'en faire plus ou en
tout cas parce que c'est compliqué la
négociation j'aurais des prix avec les
fournisseurs faut penser que dans un
supermarché traditionnel on peut on peut
se retrouver avec plus de 30000
références donc
de penser qu'on renégocier un gel des
prix de façon uniforme et aussi ce ne
sont pas les l'ensemble des fournisseurs
n'ont pas nécessairement les mêmes
hausses de coups en termes de matière
première on sait qu'on a eu des
augmentations de coûts au niveau du
transport au niveau de la main d'oeuvre
donc et on s'attend aussi à des
fluctuations durant les mois qui
viennent donc de dire de geler les prix
surtout pour les plus petits
fournisseurs qui ont moins de
flexibilité
ça voudrait dire que ce serait les
fournisseurs qui comprennent davantage
parce que pour les distributeurs je vais
en général ont plus de pouvoir de
négociation avec les fournisseurs mes
métros madame labret a entendre
aujourd'hui en répondant à l'annonce de
loblock c'est une pratique d'industrie
d'étrangelle de prix au cours de cette
période-là de l'année pour l'ensemble
des produits d'épicerie du moins chez
Métro est-ce que c'est le cas pour les
autres grandes chaînes
on peut dire que c'est je reste une
pratique courante parce que les prix
sont négociés n'ont pas à la semaine
pour une période avec les fournisseurs
donc
à ce moment-là à moins que le
distributeur va augmenter ses prix de
façon je dirais direct à ce moment-là
c'est pas une pratique qui est
habituelle surtout qu'on arrive dans une
période très compétitive puis
l'inflation est importante on est
peut-être en période de
parler de récession mais en tout cas on
peut penser que certains certains
ménages se sont subissent des conditions
financières plus difficiles donc ce
serait pas justifié et
on c'est quelque chose qu'on remarque
d'avoir une stabilité on a vu les prix
changer de façon assez importante au
cours des derniers mois mais c'est
inhabituel alors on peut pas dire que
les prix changent de façon d'une façon
assez récurrente sur une période depuis
longtemps c'est un contexte particulier
il y a plusieurs raisons qui expliquent
ce contexte là mais madame la vraie
qu'on se pose quand même la question
parce que cette décision là survient
alors que du côté d'Ottawa on s'est
entendu pour tenir une enquête sur les
profits des épiciers et de cette
manière-là tenter de les forcer à être
plus transparent sur le processus pour
établir les prix est-ce qu'on doit y
voir un lien de cause à effet est-ce que
les pressions politiques sont en ligne
de compte toujours ici il y a des
pressions politiques mais aussi les
discussions se font au niveau politique
ce ne sont pas nécessairement tous
reliés j'aurais au prix au prix de
détails mais davantage au niveau de la
négociation avec les fournisseurs tous
les fournisseurs n'ont pas le même
pouvoir de négociation par rapport à la
grande entreprise au grand distributeurs
les multinationales ont plus de pouvoir
de négociation parce qu'elles ont plus
de volume elles ont si on compare à des
petits transformateurs par exemple le
Québécois qui ont de faibles mais aussi
qu'on marque moins connue donc dans les
pratiques des grandes distributeurs on
sait que la concurrence est très très
forte puis pour aller jouer justement
sur les marges bien on va essayer de
négocier des promotions ou des escomptes
auprès des différents transformateurs
donc faut faire attention
je vais tout le monde n'est pas égal
dans la négociation de prix alors c'est
une question de volume c'est une
question de notoriété de marque de
d'attraction de différenciation aussi
plus le produit est unique plus le
produit répond un besoin très bien de
luxe moins le consommateur va être
sensible au prix très bien merci
beaucoup madame labret pour votre
analyse ce soir
je vous en prie pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI